les mettre à l'épreuve sera nécessaire
cinq clones améliorée
plus performant que toute une armée
ils font preuve d'un inquiétant niveau
de désobéissance et de mépris désordre
c'est tout ce que vos amis avec notre
section il ya que des coups à prendre
c'est pas grave on fait notre travail
clown force 99
tu sais qui omet ntaires on décolle
et qu il perdra et opérationnels tête
hyperespace
ok on fait tout exploser
il transfère je t'attends
ce sera bien suffisant
qu'ils retrouvent la clown force 99 et
qu'il rase son campement
la galaxie est un endroit dangereux
on va sortir d'ici
qu'est-ce que tu décides tu vas te
joindre à nous qu'est ce que c'est
la guerre des clones est finie
[Musique]
vous pouvez vous adaptez survivre
ou mourir avec le passé
[Musique]
la décision vous appartient
on fait les choses à notre façon
[Musique]
assieds toi ici